faze clan is defying expectations at
valorant champions tour n a masters
recently i saw this team ranked top
three at best
but they've proven that their aggressive
style of play
isn't just them pugging it's a
legitimate strategy that can win
games key to that strategy has been baby
bay on jet
so you know i had to ask him a little
bit about how they do it
i think i think people were just looking
like a lot of these players were just
looking at overwatch and being like yeah
like
oh like you play reinhardt or something
you know what i mean but that's not the
case you know there's actually a lot of
aim that goes into it and that's why
um we are like pretty like faze is
pretty much like one of the most
mechanically gifted
teams out there you know like none of us
are tank players
maybe it's because four of these players
came from overwatch
or maybe it's because they failed to
find their stride earlier in valerian
but whatever the reason it's time to
stop sleeping on faze clan
and it's time to embrace the shmee
[Music]
before we delve into the mysteries of
the shmig i have to ask
why aren't you subbed to the channel hit
the subscribe button
ring the notification bell and that way
you'll know as soon as this fresh
content is available for those eyeballs
faze clan has had the same player roster
for the past seven
months they added analyst trippy in
november before recently promoting him
to head coach
this month the roster featured four
overwatch players
baby bay corey zachary and raucous
and they added a fifth a cs player in
marved
as you probably know by now early on in
the pro scene it was the former
counter-strike players
not the overwatch players that got the
hype for a lot of that time
faze clan was considered a good but
certainly not
dominant roster that perception started
to change when they swept
hundred thieves at the final n.a masters
qualifier
on march 7th now this past weekend faze
head coach trippy tweeted something
interesting after his team's wins over
x-set
and envy he said that his team's
aggressive approach to the game
is an inherently anti-cs go strategy
i'm not saying faze isn't tactical like
i don't want that to be confused
they are and they have improved so
[ __ ] much
since adding coach trippy on their team
like it's night and day
like from a month ago they're way
way better as a team since adding that
guy as a coach
they're playing a very different style
and it might be the style to play
like they're playing the correct style
we just took a step back and like also
like we stopped trialing a lot of
coaches and we let
our coach now who's coach trippy do his
thing with us like he did
when we had the initial success and uh
everything just like felt like it was
just coming back together again and we
found it like a new place that way it's
still aggressive
we still do crazy things but there's
like a reason behind it now
now this approach has come to be known
as schmiegeng
a reference to the greedy hobbit turned
smelly cave dweller smeagle
or gollum from the lord of the rings
now trippy apparently had a hand in
coining the term
but after this weekend it's really
exploded in popularity in the valorant
community
baby bay explained his understanding of
the term on a recent edition of the
platchat ballarat podcast
so when you're just running in and like
you just don't you just give no
you know part of my french like that's
that's megan man like you're just going
for it you know you're going full smee
i like to look at us now as like the
sophisticated to me so it's like
we've evolved a little bit where you
know like we're actually like
sneaking for a purpose but obviously
just running in blindly
won't actually be a winning strategy
against the best teams
especially those who have players with
years of experience in cs go
right well aggression is only part of
what schmiegen is really about
because another huge part of it is being
as hard to read as possible
one of trippy's goals was to make faze's
playstyle the most
unpredictable in the game that is the
play around the face that's where they
want to be
that's where they do their best work and
they are just crushing it
again oh no no
not like this this past weekend at
masters
faze defeated both except and envy in
2-0 matches
and the schmieg was on full display
they're aggressive even on defense
they're willing to play retake because
of baby bay's jet and corey's rays
swaps out for the vandal the dash across
he's got a lot to deal with right now if
he played the swing correctly
it shouldn't be possible for baby babe
oh no no no
way they make that happen and neither
opponent had much in the way of an
answer
he's obviously very ready for this oh my
goodness
zach was not even incredibly quick to
that fight and
still be an easy 2k
it's just not oh
it's just disgusting to watch but why
exactly
is this playstyle so effective for faze
i mean lots of people call this game a
cs go clone right
it can't be good to hold w i asked baby
bae about his team's aggressive style
and
how it compares to a slower approach you
try to get a pick and once you're up
numbers like
they're missing so much more than you
are at that point because you're forcing
them to run in without like one of their
big util heroes let's say you killed
like a breach
like now what now what are you gonna do
now you're running into a site against
people that like
are on heroes that are like are meant
for dueling i think when you have like
people like you know me and corey that
are just like
really like annoying to deal with i feel
like for teams
that's what i've been told by like other
teams like where like like we do
random stuff you know what i mean like
stuff that people don't expect i think
it's just hard to deal with for these
people
another huge part of it is that baby bay
has by his own admission
made progress in really figuring jet out
and pushing her to her limit he's
getting creative and giving his
opponents
different looks i kind of know like the
jet boundaries very well now
and i'm a lot smarter and it's getting
me a lot more kills like three kills
like
like yeah like i get that first pick or
second pick and then like if i just like
if i
i know i know like okay i can probably
push this
but you know what and teams probably
expect i'm gonna push for more kills
but you know what if i sit back and i
play it like like a cringe corner cringe
angle off angle
i'll probably get more kills that way so
you know it's just like
i just added more depth into my gameplay
and it's not just so like
one-dimensional where i'm just always
just going going going
the rest of the team supports this
playstyle too
corey for example is a cunning race
player
who uses satchel charges to escape
sticky situations
but also to further pressure opponents
by creating new angles
okay now that we know what it actually
is
this schmieging thing has really blown
up it's not only
fun to watch it's a pretty funny meme
that both faze clan and baby bae have
embraced
and baby bay has doubled down on his
twitch stream
referring to his fans as the shmig
academy
and he even made an emote so his fans
can take the meme
even deeper none subs balding for
schmidty mo
hey yeah just just just uh
just sub forehead
i was just playing i'm just playing well
maybe we'll try to get a bt tv
one some kind of schmidt some kind of
like budget
budget between the meme his coming out
party in his last few matches
and his own hilarious personality baby
bay's twitch viewership has
exploded still left the game he left the
game
no yeah hey somebody go and spawn and
kill kill their uh
kill their breach all i'm saying is
their breach left the game and they went
around
yo he rage quits and they win around
personally i'd love to see a whole
summer
of shmee
[Music]
but there's one more thing that makes
this team so exciting like i said before
it's composed of four overwatch players
and a cs player who never cracked tier
one
listen while valorent may have some
agent abilities that feel more at home
in
overwatch the weapons maps and
strategies
are far closer to cs so naturally
many assumed that cs players would be
front runners
especially in this early period of the
game when things are still being figured
out but when i talked to baby bay
he told me that overwatch experience was
a different kind of preparation
and one that had its own advantages when
i come to this game it's just like
oh my god like i'm i'm using an op and i
don't have to shoot them in the head i
can just shoot them in the body once and
they're dead like
come on dude you know like i'm sitting
here shooting roadhogs
like five times in the head to kill them
as widows it's like that's so
so annoying another thing he pointed out
was that overwatch has a strong
vertical element shooting a widow that's
using her grapple or
sniping a flying pharah requires
movements that just aren't as common in
cs
but with jet's dashes or raises satchel
sometimes your enemy is literally
dropping in on you and valerian so while
many teams in various regions have
suggested that the game will inevitably
slow down faze are flooring it
embracing the chaos and daring their
opponents to figure them out
and listen at this early stage of
competition that's an
exciting prospect on friday faze will
face off against sentinels
in winners finals and baby bay intends
will have the chance to go
head to head we actually did a video
about the tens situation
so be sure to check that out if you
haven't yet there were obviously still
questions about the roster even with
tens's firepower
how would he be able to fit into
sentinel's system who the hell would
play jet
would shazam be able to figure out the
best way for
all of this to work and to that last
question
the answer was a resounding yes at the
beginning of the year it was in their
ability to
take specifically against sentinels but
now that tens is in the fold
i don't know that you're going to be
nearly as effective as you were before
the ace is stolen but it doesn't matter
faze clan could be changing our
perceptions of what competitive valorem
can be
whether the schmieg remains dominant or
teams adapt to the pressure
faze clan is simply one of the most
exciting teams in esports today
i consider i consider him to be the
chariot bro
because he he go forward bro
maybe there's like literally one person
who watches this video
who's like either they like understand
like the symbolism or
they just played persona who knows and
they're like oh yeah baby they just like
he's going forward all the time speaking
and he chose the chariot that makes so
much sense but there's gonna be like
exactly one human being
everybody else is gonna be like i have
no [ __ ] idea what that car means
i'm ashamed to admit this but i
literally changed
my riot id to schmieg of legends i think
it's pretty dank but
you can only change it once every 30
days so if this thing burns out in 30
days bro people are gonna be like what
the hell
personally i'd love to see a whole
summer
of schmieg yeah you know you're just i'd
love to just sit in my backyard
you know watch the sunset see some sneak